Okay. Last week,
Democrats in California introduced a Bill that
would ban the sale and the use of rodent glue traps.
According to the Bill,
these glue traps are very inhumane,
and they're not nice.
Now, I know you're probably wondering,
like, aren't there
bigger problems facing Americans right now? Like,
shouldn't the politicians be focusing on something else?
And you're probably right.
But I do wanna talk about this for a minute,
because these are the exact same people who,
back in 2022,
almost unanimously
voted in favor of a Bill that allows abortion
up till the point of birth
for any reason,
no questions asked.
Now, however you feel about that law,
however you feel about abortion,
general, pro life,
pro choice, whatever,
have you ever heard a Congress person,
a politician,
anybody, advocate for more humane abortions?
Have you ever heard anybody question
how abortions are done,
and are they done humanely
and as the fetus feel the pain?
Because the science behind
when a fetus can feel pain is constantly changing,
and it gets earlier and earlier and earlier.
It's just wild to me that in this country
we prioritize literal rats above human beings.